I'm really free to let them try anything
as long as it's not something dangerous
or not age-appropriate
speaking of age-appropriate Travis
Barker is not here for creepy DMS
especially when they involve his
underage daughter Alabama the 43 year
old musician spoke out on Thursday after
learning a 20 year old drummer Graham
sirota has been direct messaging his 13
year old daughter the echosmith band
member has reportedly been messaging
alabama compliments and party invites
since 2016 I allow them to do really
whatever they want a young age like
they've dressed themselves they've
colored there hair Travis may allow his
kids to express themselves but he
doesn't want anyone getting the wrong
impression Travis told the blast he was
disgusted and felt Graham's actions have
been quote predatory telling the outlet
quote there is nothing cool normal or
okay about it at all now Graham is
apologizing for his actions in a
statement released to ET on Thursday the
drummer admits he was unaware of
Alabama's age quote I didn't realize she
was a minor and assumed she was my age
I made a careless mistake and this is a
big lesson for me I would like to
apologize again to Alabama
her dad Travis and her family
you